[Música]
hola una vez escuché la siguiente
expresión la tecnología resuelve los
problemas humanos
esta afirmación me llamó la atención me
quedé pensando
luego la escuchado más veces quizá
algunos de ustedes lo recuerde en el año
2020 hubo una pandemia cuando todo
empezó nos mandaron a casa cerraron las
escuelas los museos los mercados los
parques e incluso los bares la pandemia
imponía su ley
hay que parar el hecho es que cuando
cerraron las escuelas de repente lo más
importante era que niñas y niñas no
perdieran clases
no deja de ser extraño porque alguien
recuerda el contenido de sus clases
cuando tenía nueve años
y cuando tenía 14 yo tampoco todos
sabemos que la educación no está
funcionando muy bien que realmente no
nos ayuda a entender y abordar los
grandes retos de la vida
pero llega una pandemia y concluimos que
el curriculum es lo más importante
cuidado no sea que vayamos a perder el
tiempo la pandemia nos estaba diciendo
hay que parar pues porque no paramos y
escuchamos qué es lo que necesitamos
aprender aquello que normalmente no
tenemos tiempo de abordar paramos tal
vez esta sea la oportunidad para
escuchar que nos está enseñando la
escuela sobre la vida y sobre la muerte
sobre la educación la vocación las
relaciones nuestra relación con el mundo
pero en lugar de eso decidimos no perder
clase
el objetivo era mantener todo lo más
parecido posible a como era antes aunque
antes no funcionara seguro que alguien
pensó que suerte que esta pandemia ha
llegado en el siglo 21 que tenemos
internet móviles ordenadores relojes
inteligentes y que podemos seguir
haciendo lo mismo desde cualquier lugar
luego nos dimos cuenta que ese lugar
solo podía ser uno tu casa entonces se
multiplicaron las tecnologías en los
colegios y en las universidades en los
hospitales y en los supermercados en las
administraciones públicas y en las casas
de la gente
y donde no había suficiente pues se
ponía más más móviles y más ordenadores
más antenas y conexiones más rápidas más
aplicaciones y plataformas en la nube
la pandemia nos estaba diciendo hay que
parar
pero pensamos que la tecnología era la
solución al problema
la gente hablaba por videoconferencias
cuando no podían quedar a dar un paseo
por el barrio pero cuando pudieron salir
a pasear siguieron hablando por
videoconferencias era un poco raro algo
no iba bien como que no todo parecía tan
bueno como nos habían contado
el problema de la escuela seguía
haciendo como educar a los jóvenes para
la vida pero la escuela estaba tan
ocupada volviéndose online que ya no lo
recordaba
entonces nos juntamos un grupo de amigos
y empezamos a investigar por nuestra
cuenta empezamos a observar a aquellas
gentes observamos sus cuerpos moviéndose
sus cuerpos a veces inmóviles cuerpos
inmóviles usando móviles y seguimos
observando eureka habíamos encontrado
algo que cuerpo se nos queda con estas
tecnologías que tenemos
el corazón ha quedado encerrado en el
fondo del pecho
qué cuerpo se nos queda con estas
tecnologías que tenemos
[Música]
claro
y claro
toda una vida atrapada en nuestras
cabezas
el cuerpo es el vehículo que transporta
nuestra cabeza de un lugar a otro
qué cuerpo se nos queda con estas
tecnologías que tenemos
estoy muy preocupado
es que no sé qué decirles
acción
y además tengo la sensación de que yo
y
voy a mirar en internet seguro que a uno
y creemos que somos más libres
como no estamos a lo que estamos
obedecemos sin darnos cuenta obedecemos
a fin de cuentas que cuerpo se nos queda
con estas tecnologías que tenemos
las voces duelen sobre todo cuando se
mantiene el largo tiempo
también duele no poder ser una misma
qué cuerpo se nos queda con estas
tecnologías que tenemos
las emociones fuertes se van tan rápido
como llegan mientras el presente
se nos escapa
el cuerpo nunca es solo el cuerpo el
cuerpo nos explica cómo estamos en el
mundo nos muestra la actitud que tenemos
ante la vida
la estética y la ética están en el
cuerpo al mismo tiempo cuando decimos
que cuerpo se nos queda estamos diciendo
que vida estamos viviendo
sabemos que esto pasa lo vemos
constantemente a nuestro alrededor
seguramente nos hemos visto reflejados
aquí verdad estas escenas recuerdan a
tiempos modernos de chaplin ese apretar
tornillos en la cadena de producción o
ese artefacto que alimenta al obrero
para que no tenga que hacer siquiera la
pausa del almuerzo
recuerdo un profesor de electrónica que
estaba conmocionado porque sus
estudiantes de ingeniería se inspiraban
en la ciencia ficción veían capítulos de
black mirror y deseabas deseaban ser
ellos quienes en el futuro crearan esas
tecnologías tan sorprendentes
quizás hubiera sido necesario analizar
esos relatos quizás hubiera sido
necesario pararse a pensar
que el humor y las distopías lo que
realmente pretenden es alertar nos
señalará aquello que no funciona
nos hemos preguntado qué cuerpo se nos
queda con estas tecnologías creemos que
es una pregunta importante pero también
es importante que nos preguntemos por
qué pasa esto porque se quedan así los
cuerpos hemos encontrado algunas causas
evidentes pero que muchas veces pasan
desapercibidas
porque se quedan así los cuerpos
porque estas tecnologías que tenemos
están diseñadas para enganchar
respondí a response
sí
seguro que quiere salir del mundo
porque se quedan así los cuerpos porque
estas tecnologías que tenemos utilizan
un lenguaje que confunde y oculta la
verdad
bienvenidos
sigue tus cosas
nuestro
[Música]
en parte
a generar tráfico en nuestra red
tus heridos tus amigos tus amigos
mis contactos
porque se quedan así los cuerpos porque
estas tecnologías que tenemos activan
las pasiones humanas activan el deseo de
que te acepten los demás la avaricia la
envidia la ira el placer rápido
yo también
[Música]
está todo mal
días
[Música]
en estantes
[Aplausos]
me gusta
[Música]
porque se quedan así los cuerpos porque
estas tecnologías que tenemos se
sostienen sobre la explotación de las
personas y de los recursos naturales
bien
e
y
bien
i
porque si quedan así los cuerpos porque
estas tecnologías que tenemos no son
neutrales tienen que hacer más ricos a
sus dueños a cualquier precio
mujer
a mí me gusta
nuestra
nombran
un gran hombre
el tema como podemos comprobar no se
puede resolver diciendo que las
tecnologías no resuelven los problemas
no la tecnología también crea problemas
por eso estamos en crisis y por eso
estamos hoy aquí para identificar y
comprender los problemas que crea la
producción y el consumo que hacemos de
estas tecnologías y también para
plantear respuestas coherentes por dónde
empezar
empecemos por imaginar un mundo cuyo
progreso fundamental sea el de hacernos
más humanos
un mundo donde los humanos seamos cada
vez más humanos
un mundo donde la escuela eduqué a los
jóvenes para la vida con toda su
complejidad
un mundo donde la tecnología ocupe sólo
el lugar que le corresponde
un mundo donde se desarrollan
tecnologías que no enganchan
tecnologías
que se presentan tal y como son con sus
aportaciones y sus limitaciones sin
engaños tecnologías que permiten a las
personas ser ellas mismas y poner la
vida en el centro tecnologías que se
construyan con trabajo digno y que tomen
de la naturaleza sólo lo necesario
tecnologías que sirvan al bien común y
que sostengan el progreso de la
humanidad
se imagina
no hay tiempo que perder necesitamos
este mundo nuevo como lo haremos poco a
poco paso a paso primero un pie y
después el otro primero un pie y después
el otro
podemos empezar actuando con mayor
conciencia en nuestro día a día
un día te llamaré por teléfono en lugar
de grabar un audio porque quiero
encontrarme contigo
otro día apagaré las notificaciones del
móvil porque quiero habitar el silencio
y encontrarme por fin conmigo misma
otro día hablaré con mis amigos para
acordar respetarnos nuestros tiempos
para no exigir nos respuestas inmediatas
para permitirnos descansar
otro día borraré un montón de cosas que
tengo guardadas en la nube y que nunca
miro para no malgastar recursos del
planeta
otro día dejará de utilizar aplicaciones
gratuitas de grandes empresas
multinacionales y empezaré a utilizar
aplicaciones creadas por pequeñas
empresas locales generando economía y
trabajo digno en mi barrio
otro día me uniré a un taller
comunitario donde aprenderá a reparar mi
ordenador para que dure más
y así paso a paso
estos son pequeñas cosas ejemplos para
que podáis empezar hoy mismo y pronto
veréis resultados os animo a hacerlo de
verdad
también es verdad que hace falta un
cambio más grande
tenemos una mala noticia
todas las revoluciones industriales han
perseguido de una forma u otra el máximo
beneficio para unos pocos y han oprimido
de diferentes maneras a la mayoría la
explotación de la humanidad a lo largo
de la historia ha tomado diferentes
formas pero en esencia es lo mismo
formas de alejarnos de una vida plena de
una vida digna
también tenemos una buena noticia en
anteriores revoluciones hubo personas
que vieron lo que se les venía encima
y que se organizaron y lucharon por sus
derechos y para que las máquinas y el
progreso técnico nunca sean a costa de
ningún ser humano
el movimiento judith a su poder la
violencia de las máquinas contra sus
cuerpos el movimiento obrero se levantó
por la dignidad de las personas
trabajadoras y exigió un tiempo de
descanso y también un tiempo de
promoción es decir de desarrollo
personal y comunitario
el movimiento del software libre surgió
para poner la informática los
ordenadores al servicio de las personas
hoy también parece urgente un movimiento
de personas que quieran protagonizar sus
propias vidas
un movimiento de gentes modernas que
quieran devolver la tecnología al lugar
que le corresponde
un movimiento que busque una salida
humana a los problemas humanos
un movimiento de personas que quieran
vivir humanamente y sostener solo
aquellas tecnologías acordes con el
progreso humano
sin eso de qué sirve que todos los niños
no pierdan un día de clase que tengan
todas las tecnologías a su disposición
la educación es importante sin duda
siempre y cuando nos ayude a todos a los
niños ya nosotros a ser más humanos a
ser más profundamente humanos la
tecnología no debe ser nunca un
obstáculo en ese camino
cuando tengamos dudas
escuchemos qué nos dice nuestro cuerpo
gracias
[Aplausos]